The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Here we have a
near miss learning tree.
It's a little bit different
but a little bit similar.
We've got different types.
We're trying to learn about
different light sources.
So we're concerned about
different lamps, flashlights,
all sorts of things.
So these guys can have had types
of support, a base or wires.
The base can be flat,
clamped, or have legs.
The legs can be flat
bottomed or wheeled.
The light source can be
incandescent, fluorescent,
or sodium vapor.
And the energy
source that powers it
can be electric,
battery, oil, or gas.
So there's also
some other things.
But these are the trees
that we might be climbing up
with the climb-tree heuristic.
Our starting model is we
have an incandescent bulb.
The height is equal
to 24 inches exactly.
They have a flat base.
There's electricity to power it.
And it has a shade.
So our starting model is
basically like a table lamp
that you set on the table.
It's got the shade
over the top of it.
You know, the standard
room table lamp
is our starting model.
So recall in arch
learning, which
is what we are using here, that
there are several heuristics
that we might want to use.
Let's see, well, the
heuristics are-- we've
got require-link, forbid-link.
We've got climb-tree,
extend-set, close-interval.
And we also have drop-link--
forgot about that one.
That's sort of with the links.
I can put it here.
OK, so if you want to do
well on these questions
if they appear on the
final, first of all,
you better know what
those six heuristics do.
So basically require-link
is a heuristic.
It goes into your
model as a requirement,
where before your
model just didn't care.
So let's say there was something
about color for your light,
like for your lamp's
base or for the lamp.
And right, now it doesn't
care about color at all.
But let's say that you wound
up having an example that was,
for instance, blue or white
or whatever these colors are.
And it wound up getting that
blue was OK for-- in its model,
it wound up getting, OK,
blue and white are OK.
Or actually, no, an even
more basic example--
let's say that it just kept
getting blue lamps as examples,
and all of them were blue.
And it just didn't care about
the fact that they were blue.
But they did turn
out to be blue.
And then eventually
it found a red one
that was exactly the
same as its model,
but the red one was a near miss.
Then it might
require blue, which
was already an acceptable,
permissible thing in its model.
But it could be required.
Now, another thing
it can do is forbid.
Some people ask me, why
would you bother saying,
forbid red, say, if you can
already just require blue?
Together they cover
the same ground.
The answer is because this
system, this arch learning
system-- remember, it's
Patrick's doctoral thesis.
It's an old system.
Because it was
built on old systems
and because also it's
generally a good idea,
it was very parsimonious.
Let's say you had
a set of colors--
red, blue, yellow, green,
pink, purple, orange--
and you found that only orange
was giving you problems,
you could try to require
that it be in this.
Or you could even
use extend-set,
make a giant set of red, blue,
yellow, green, purple, pink,
but not orange.
But if you just
forbid orange, you've
just saved a whole
bunch of space,
particularly if there's a
large possible series of set.
You want to have the
ability to forbid.
Because it needs to have the
smallest model that it can
that covers all of its samples.
So we also have climb-tree.
Climb-tree takes one of
the elements in our model
and moves up the tree one level.
So let's say we said, only
incandescent lights are good.
But we found that fluorescent
lights are also good.
Whoop, we move up to
light source, climb-tree.
Extend-set-- we don't
have any sets here.
But let's go back to red,
blue, orange, yellow.
Extend-set is when we say,
only red is good as an example.
But we see another positive
example that's yellow.
So we say, OK, I'll
extend the set.
Red and yellow are both good.
All right, close-interval--
close-interval
is really obvious when
you need to use it.
Because not only is it only
used for intervals like height
equals 24 inches or
some kind of numbers,
but it is the only thing
you can use for when height
equals some kind of numbers.
Close-interval will let you
fuss around with the intervals
and say, oh, well I guess one
with a 20 inch height is OK,
too.
So we'll make the whole
interval 20 to 24 inches good.
Because it doesn't make any
sense for it to be like,
20 is good, 24 is good, but
nothing in between is good.
No, those are awful.
So that close-interval
covers the entire interval.
Last but not least is drop-link.
The thing about drop-link
is that drop-link is, again,
only really used due to the
fact that the system wants
to be as parsimonious as
possible with its model.
Drop-link is-- let's say you
have a color, and you're like,
OK, only red is acceptable.
And then you see a blue one.
It's OK.
And let's say red, blue, and
yellow are your only colors.
Only red and blue
are acceptable.
Hey, wait a minute.
No, we can just say
that only yellow
is not acceptable, or
something like that, all right?
But then you see yellow
as a positive example.
Actually, you can't even
switch to the yellow being
not acceptable,
because you've only
seen positive of red and blue.
So you say, only red
and blue are acceptable.
Question?
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that if we
had seen incandescent
and fluorescent,
it's OK that we could climb
the tree to light source,
because it's more parsimonious.
If we then see one that's
sodium vapor, say a street lamp,
and we reject it, do we have
to go back down the tree,
or do we just add a forbid-link?
PROFESSOR: Then you
would add a forbid-link.
The question is, we climb
incandescent, fluorescent,
to light source.
When we see sodium
vapor, what do we do?
The answer is, our system,
unlike with lattice learning,
in arch learning, our
system is memoryless
of its previous examples.
It's incapable of going
back down the tree.
And so if you see
incandescent and fluorescent,
climb up to light source,
you're only recourse,
if you see that sodium
vapor doesn't work,
is to forbid-link sodium vapor.
That's a good question.
It shows good understanding
of how we work.
So drop-link, as you see, red
and blue, they both are OK.
You don't know about yellow,
so you can't just switch that
to a forbid-link to yellow.
But then you see
yellow is also OK.
What do you do?
You can drop the
link altogether,
save yourself space.
If all the colors that you have
in the entire world are fine,
you can just not have part
of your model be the color,
and just say, any color is fine.
Color must not be really
part of what defines a lamp.
And I'd say it's not.
I mean, it's what defines
a tacky lamp, I guess.
But it's not what
defines a lamp.
So that might be why color
isn't here to begin with.
So to make yourself
do better on this,
more knowledge
equals less search.
Let's have more knowledge.
There's only some of these
are used to generalize,
to make our model more
accepting of new examples.
And those are ones we
would use after we've
seen a positive hit,
sort of generalize,
learn more things in the model.
Some of these are used
to specialize and make
our model refined, make
our model more specific.
You'd only use those
after you saw a near miss.
So let's actually
separate those.
That way you guys
will never make
the mistake of using one of
these in the wrong situation.
And more knowledge, less search.
And less search means
a faster quiz time.
So require-link, what
do you guys think?
Is that a specializer
or a generalizer?
AUDIENCE: Specializer.
PROFESSOR: Specializer,
that's right.
We'd only use it when
we saw a near miss.
Forbid-link, specializer
or generalizer?
AUDIENCE: Specializer.
PROFESSOR: Specializer.
We'd only forbid something
if we saw a miss.
Climb-tree, specializer
or generalizer?
AUDIENCE: Generalizer
PROFESSOR: Generalizer,
that's right.
We'd only climb up to a more
generic thing in the tree
if we saw a positive example.
Extend-set?
AUDIENCE: Generalizer.
PROFESSOR: Generalizer.
We'd only extend the
things in our set
if we saw a positive example.
Close-interval?
AUDIENCE: Generalizer.
PROFESSOR: That's a generalizer.
We'd only make the
interval bigger
if we saw a positive example.
Someone asks, what do you do
if you have like 10 to 30,
and then you find a
negative example in 20?
It's generally pretty
annoying for this system
to have to deal with that.
There's a variety of
things you could do
based on your implementation.
I've never seen us
ask it in a quiz.
But one thing you could do is
forbid 20, exactly just 20,
and just have a little
hole at exactly 20.
So then drop-link--
specializer or generalizer?
AUDIENCE: Generalizer.
PROFESSOR: Generalizer.
This one's an easy
one to mess up
if you don't
understand the system.
Because dropping, you think,
oh, getting rid of something.
That's specializing.
But actually no, you're
generalizing the entire area
saying, we can forget about it.
Because they're all good.
All right, so given that, we
are set to do this problem.
Hey, we have a pretty
reasonable amount
of time considering that we
don't have to do our sums.
It's great.
So our first example
is sort of one
of those stand reading lights
that you sort of have it
on a stand, and you can
adjust the little light
bulb up or down.
It is an incandescent bulb.
It has a height of 11 inches.
And it's got a flat base.
It's electric.
It's got a shade.
And it's a hit.
It's a hit, a positive
example, a plus.
It's good.
So right away, we know
that we can only use
the S's or the G's?
The G's.
We can only use the G's.
Because it's a hit.
So we're not going
to be requiring.
We're not to be
forbidding today.
We're going to be happy
and using a generalizer.
So I'll help do the first one.
You guys will help
me do the next one.
Or someone can say,
we didn't cover this,
and I'll do the first
one, and we'll stop.
So we've got an
incandescent light.
That's the same as our model.
We've got a height of 11 inches.
Oh, our model only covers 24.
Flat base-- that's
the same as our model.
Electricity-- same as our model.
Shade-- same as our model.
So I say the only
difference is the height.
I say we need to close the
interval, close-interval.
And I say that our model
is the same as before,
except for that height is
an element of 11 to 24.
Simple enough-- I picked
the easy one for myself.
Next one.
So this one is going to be-- the
picture here didn't turn out.
But it's basically a lamp
that doesn't have a shade.
It just sort of has the
light shining on you.
So it is a positive example.
It's incandescent, height
equals 11.5, flat base,
and electricity.
All right, so first
of all, which kind
would we use, specializing
or generalizing?
AUDIENCE: Generalizing.
PROFESSOR: Generalizing,
and particularly,
anyone want to take a
look at our model, which
is the starting model, except
for the height can go 11 to 24?
Which heuristic do
we need to use here?
AUDIENCE: Drop-link.
PROFESSOR: All right, people
are all saying drop-link.
Yes, that's right.
Someone said extend-set.
Well, I suppose we could extend
the set to shade or not shade.
But that's everything.
So drop-link is the answer.
We can drop the shade.
Shade or not, this is
still pretty much a lamp.
So that's correct.
We drop-link.
So the model--
all right, there's
been enough changes to it that
I think I'll write it out again.
The model is
incandescent, height
equals an element from 11 to 24,
and flat base, and electricity.
Good, so question?
AUDIENCE: So during
this all, we're
editing our model based on the
order that the model is in,
right?
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
we're editing the model based
on the order of the examples?
AUDIENCE: What
happens if there's
the same thing except with no
shade or something like that
afterwards?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, what
happens if you have the same
thing except for that there's
one that's the same with no
shades and is a near miss
or something so
that you need to--
or I'm sorry, you're saying,
what if there's one that has
a shade now that's a near miss?
And so it would probably
try to forbid-link shades.
That's sort of the question?
You're right.
That's an inconsistency
in the data.
The system is very fragile.
It's very fragile to
ordering in particular.
And you'd be
surprised how awesome
this does considering that it
was made in, like, the '60s.
It's pretty impressive stuff.
But it's old.
We're not saying that this
is a way that you should do
all of your learning nowadays.
Because it has some
serious issues.
It's old, but it's pretty
damn good for what it did.
A newer style of this kind
of learning made by me
and another friend who's
now working at Google
is lattice learning, which
has its own share of issues,
one of which is that
since it's trying
to act like a little
kid, at first it
tries to claim that everything
is OK until you show it
some good negative examples.
But very particularly
one way gets around
this problem is
it's not memoryless.
It in fact stores
all of the examples
it's ever seen and
compares and contrasts them
to what it sees in
the new example.
And this allows it
to say something
like-- let's say you're trying
to teach it what can fly.
In lattice learning, you say,
all right, well, a blue jay
can fly.
And then if you ask it,
can a cow fly, sure,
a cow jumped over the moon.
Everything can fly.
So that's its problem.
But if you say, actually,
that was a nursery rhyme,
a cow cannot in fact
fly, it will then say,
only birds can fly.
Because it remembers that
the blue jay can fly.
And then you can eventually say,
well, actually bats can fly,
a fruit bat can fly.
Well, OK, so chiropterans
can fly and birds can fly.
But that's it.
And you can give it
some other examples.
But there are other
styles of learning.
You're absolutely right.
In fact, if there's a
multiple choice asking you
about the strengths and
weaknesses of arch learning,
one of the weaknesses-- it's
very vulnerable to ordering
of what you teach it.
But think about it.
If our first example
was one that's
exactly the same as
this but with a shade,
and it was a miss, the system
would just yell at you.
Like, you're kind of being an
asshole to it to give it two
things that are inconsistent.
You might say in the
real world that happens.
Well, arch learning, not great
with real world messy data.
It just goes ballistic.
It's very OCD.
It wants everything to match up.
If it gets two things
that are inconsistent,
it'll just yell at you.
It's like, you're wrong.
This can't be true.
Because you said it's
OK with the shade.
So that's a very good question.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: So if
you have a sample
that had two different
things for the model,
and it's a near miss--
PROFESSOR: It's not a near miss.
The question is, if
you have something
with two different things in the
model, and it's a near miss--
and I'm sorry to cut you off.
Based on timing, I'm
just going to say,
whatever you said
afterwards doesn't
apply due to the fact at that
point it's not a near miss.
It's very important.
It's only a near miss if
there's only one change.
Otherwise, it's just a miss.
And if it's a miss with
more than one change,
you were probably going to say,
how do you know what to change?
The answer is, you
can't change anything.
Because any of them could
have been what was wrong.
That's why for a hit, oh, it
can have as many differences
as you want.
You'll just generalize them all.
For a miss, it can only
have one thing different.
In fact, there might be one
here that's not a near miss,
and you just say, oh,
we don't do anything.
We'll keep going.
We might see it if we have time.
So question?
AUDIENCE: Because ordering
is an important factor
for this bigger thing,
and you encounter an item
which has two
discrepancies in values,
but if the ordering
were different such
that that would
be accounted for,
do you remember if you turn
back to that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, let's say
you have a non-near miss.
Can you hold onto
it and use it later
when it would be a near miss?
The answer is, nope.
If we're going here,
for a system that
doesn't remember things,
you can put in some kludges.
That definitely
makes it smarter.
It uses all its data.
But Patrick in the '60s making
this up strove for elegance.
And the elegant solution
is, let's just be memoryless
completely, the idea
being, well, little babies
can't tell you every experience
they had with playing
with blocks with an arch.
So let's remember nothing.
With lattice
learning, our idea is
that people sort of
somewhere in the subconscious
maybe do store all the
examples, or at least a lot
more than you give
them credit for.
So why not store them?
But with arch learning, it's,
little babies can't tell you,
oh yeah, there's that one
time I played with a lamp,
and it didn't have
a shade, and so
it wasn't a lamp, or
something like that.
They're not going to
be able to store it.
They're not going to be
able to save it for later.
Sort of in the
style of Turing, who
believed a human would be
a teacher to a computer,
arch learning really
focuses on the fact
that the human is a kind
and good teacher who
offers examples that are
exactly appropriate at the time.
And that puts a lot
of pressure on you
as the trainer of an
arch learning system.
Good questions, all.
Let's continue
working this guy out.
So the next example is
basically another one
of these stand lamps.
It's got a light shining
down, which is fluorescent.
It looks like this.
It's fluorescent.
Height equals 13 inches,
flat base, electric, shade.
And yeah, as I put
here, it's a hit.
So as you guys have
told me countless times,
so I believe you
that you remember,
we're going to
generalize for the hit.
So what should we do here?
So some people are
saying extend-set.
AUDIENCE: Climb-tree.
PROFESSOR: The people who are
saying climb-tree are correct.
Why do we climb-tree
instead of extend-set?
Because of the fact that
it's a tree, not a set.
And it is more
parsimonious to climb
the tree than it is to treat
it as a set and extend the set.
Sets don't have a hierarchy.
It's just like red comma blue
comma yellow, or shade comma
not shade.
Whenever you have
a tree, it's a fact
that it's more parsimonious
to just climb it
than it is to treat it
as a set and extend it,
even though you could
do that, I suppose.
And arch learning,
it's parsimonious.
It's elegant.
It's simple.
And the elegant thing
to do-- just climb up.
So yes, we're going
to climb up the tree.
So our model is the same as last
time except that this time it
has a light source instead
of saying, incandescent.
It just climbed up to
light source, sure.
All right, so the next
one is pretty cool.
It's another one of those
fluorescent shine down lamps.
But in space, it has a
tripod with three legs.
And those legs all have wheels.
So it is also a hit.
So it is fluorescent, height
equals 14 inches, wheeled legs,
and electric.
So obviously we're generalizing.
What heuristic will
we use this time?
AUDIENCE: Climb-tree.
PROFESSOR: Climb-tree
again, that's right.
We're going to climb from flat
base to base support itself.
Because wheeled
legs and flat base,
base support is an
ancestor of both.
So our model is
the same as before.
But at this point,
it's changed enough
that I might as
well write it out.
So we'll say that it is light
source, height between 11
and 24 inches, base support,
some sort of support,
and electricity.
Awesome, now, come on parity.
Ah, no, back up, you.
There we go.
So that down there,
don't get confused.
That down there is
our most recent model.
We now have-- oh, oops, hehe.
OK, I actually missed
one of the examples.
However, we were actually
completely correct,
which gives away quite a lot.
We had a miss, incandescent
bulb-- back in the old days
when incandescent was the
only kind of light we had.
Height equals 60 inches,
flat, back in the old days
when flat was the only
one we had, electric,
back in the old days
when we had electric.
And we also have
shade after we've
dropped the link for shade.
So we know that shade or
not shade are both OK.
So the question
is, what do we do?
First of all, do we specialize
or generalize with this miss?
AUDIENCE: Specialize.
PROFESSOR: So obviously we're
only to be able to require
or forbid.
So standardly, traditionally,
the answer would be nothing.
However, we accept it
as sane the possibility
that you might put a
require onto the height.
Some students did
that, like say, oh
gosh, that's a
hard set, 11 to 24.
But that's not what
you would normally do.
So just to show that we tried
to understand that there might
be multiple ideas in
a weird situation,
we did accept that
that one time.
But generally, there's not
anything you have to do.
This system at the time, and
still now, said 11 to 24.
This is spookily exactly
the correct place
where this example would go.
But you don't have to do
anything to the model.
You don't have to
use any heuristics.
OK, so last step, -- the
question is-- oh, question.
AUDIENCE: So here, if we did
it in this particular order,
having it be the
next [INAUDIBLE]
in our example
list, then it only
differs by one from our
existing model, right?
PROFESSOR: No, it
differs by a lot.
It actually wouldn't be a
near miss if we did it out.
AUDIENCE: It would be a
PROFESSOR: No, incandescent is
different than light source.
Height is different than height.
Flat is different
than base support.
So it would differ
by a huge number,
and it would not be a near miss.
AUDIENCE: OK, then
here's a question.
Even though on the
tree incandescent
is a child branching
off of light source,
if we instead encountered--
because our current model says
light source comma
whatnot, if instead we
got a negative thing that
said, fluorescent, again,
would that be considered
not a near miss,
because fluorescent
differs from light source?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, would it
not be considered a near miss
if you had, say, fluorescent
rather than light source,
because fluorescent
differs from light source?
So the answer there is--
AUDIENCE: Since
it's memoryless, it
doesn't know that fluorescent--
PROFESSOR: Well sure,
it is memoryless.
It doesn't know that
fluorescent used to be
a positive example before.
Unfortunately, let's say
we did have an example that
was fluorescent, height
is an element of 11 to 24,
base support, electric.
Actually, let's say we have
one that was sodium vapor,
height is 13.
Sodium vapor, height
is 13, base support--
for some reason it was called
base support and electric.
That's possible, right?
We haven't seen a
positive of sodium vapor.
Let's say that sodium
vapor was not allowed.
If we don't say that that's a
near miss and then forbid-link
sodium vapor, how
are we ever going
to get rid of sodium vapor?
Unfortunately,
because of that, we
lose some amount
of expressiveness.
Actually, what you're saying is
very logical and makes sense,
that you would want to
have the ability to say,
OK, this is a subset.
This should be OK.
But unfortunately,
because of the fact
that we climbed
the tree even when
we haven't seen a positive
example for all things
in the bottom on that tree,
we actually lose that ability.
It's a trade-off.
It is most certainly a
weakness of arch learning
that you point out here.
Lattice learning fixes that,
but it has its own problems.
So you're right, that you'd
want to be able to do that.
But you can't.
Because it's memoryless.
So last but not
least, which model
would we present in order
to teach the system, right
now from its final system, that
a lamp requires a base support?
So it would need to be
require-link for the base
support.
So really fast--
incandescent bulb
with a height of 6, a flat
base, and electricity.
Would that do it?
Incandescent bulb
with a height of 8
and a battery, incandescent
bulb with a height of 12, wire
support, and electricity--
oh yeah, by the way,
this will have to be a
miss to teach a require.
Fluorescent bulb, height of 21,
clamp base, and electricity,
or incandescent
bulb, height of 12,
flat bottomed legs,
and electricity--
so did anyone pick that out over
the fastness of me saying it?
Because [INAUDIBLE] is
going to want to come in.
Question or answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's
going to have a miss.
AUDIENCE: If it's
on the wire support?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I know it was fast.
You can look through
quiz 2007 final.
Because [INAUDIBLE] is going
to come in in a minute.
But it would be a
miss on the one that
was correct on everything except
for it was a wire support.
Then the question you
have is, wait a minute,
it says incandescent bulb.
That is now a subset
of light source.
You have his question again.
The answer to that is they
must have decided here
that that was OK.
But on the other
hand, how would it
learn sodium vapor if that
wasn't decided to be OK?
That's going to have to be
an implementation detail.
So one thing you can do
is try to treat subsets
as OK in the logical way.
Because questions may do that.
And then I guess
you've lost the ability
to forbid, say, sodium vapor.
So you have to lose
one or the other.
I think you're definitely OK
to ask TAs or someone who's
proctoring if a
situation like that
comes up, which implementation
detail is chosen.
Because you could choose
either when you're running
arch learning.